what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel um today
is gonna be an episode of pearl red
pills women
and today i have a special guest on the
channel i
we met through basketball yeah
basketball yeah you wanna you wanna tell
them where they can find you yep you
guys can find me on tech talk amani on
the school xox a-m-a-n-i-e
so guys today we are showing her jordan
peterson for the first time
do you know who jordan peterson is no i
don't watch
i'm not i'm not a social person yeah no
no social media
so so jordan peterson is a psychologist
and so he in this episode he kind of
explains some things about like the pay
gap and some misconceptions about the
pay gap okay so um
before we start are you would you
consider yourself a feminist i feel like
um
i am all for women's rights and equality
but i don't know if i'm a feminist
because there's lots of there's a
i just don't understand what feminism is
basically but i do believe in women's
rights and equality yeah
yeah that's that's what i say like i i'm
all for us being able to do the same
stuff i just think sometimes feminists
take it too far like they want revenge
almost i i hear that though i understand
why they want revenge to be honest but
why
why
i feel like because
for many years we've just not been equal
so but i mean we didn't live through
that so i don't understand why we need
to get revenge but i can understand why
some people really but you have to
realize like men tamed the world so we
could be equal yeah they did actually
well it's through women like the
suffragettes and the suffragettes they
like protests and stuff like that
because at first they didn't really want
like equality no i mean like
like everything that's built in society
we wouldn't have without men like men
fight in wars and they build like
infrastructure you know what i'm saying
so it's like
like we wouldn't even be able to have
equal rights if men didn't build the
world we live in it's true it's true
because there wouldn't be like the jobs
that we have today it will mostly be
jobs about
strength some like strength work and
then there will be other jobs about like
hair and makeup kind of work yeah it
won't have like gender-neutral jobs yeah
well and like if we didn't have like
society structured and like
safe the way they are like you'd have to
depend on a guy to take care of you yeah
so it's like it's almost weird because
they fight for equality and they want
like they want to get revenge but we
wouldn't even be here without men yeah i
hear that i do understand that but i
don't understand i i do understand why
they get revenge but it's it's not
logical no it's it's so it's an
emotional it's emotional because we do
like
act on our emotions majority of the time
yeah
you ever get crazy around your period i
get a little crazy around my period i
think i'm just crazy all the time
it'd be like that i just feel like
sometimes like a lot of people do you
can tell when some girls aren't going
towards their period because they get
crazy like crazy but i just feel like
i'm that like
do you ever feel like
i feel like okay
the least crazy girls admit they're
crazy
yeah yeah but if the girls are like i'm
not crazy you're like you're kind of
yeah my friends actually like it's funny
because i admit it here but my friends
like
some of my closer friends like are like
you're actually really crazy and then my
other friends like acquaintances and
stuff they're like oh she's such a nice
girl she's like really nice and sweet
but i'm not like i pretend to be but i'm
really not what do you do like
i just feel like
i'm a person that likes to get revenge
all the time oh like i wouldn't oh i'm
so it's so crazy but i would if someone
does something to me i probably wouldn't
tell you that i'm mad but i will get
revenge how what's the craziest way
you've gotten revenge
um
when i was in secondary school
this is crazy when i was in secondary
school right me and this girl were such
good friends but then she used to do
this she used to do certain things like
let me give you an example because it's
hard to explain because i can't remember
specifically but um let's say like
someone will compliment me and then the
girl will be like oh she's just wearing
makeup or something like that you know i
mean those kind of girls that's what she
used to do to me all the time and then
it came to a point where i was like oh
[ __ ] it and then i just exposed
everything that she's done she said
about everyone
she kind of pissed me off to the point
where
so you're just it's like crazy it's
don't cross me [ __ ] yeah that kind of
stuff yeah i feel yeah because i'm
really nice until i'm not you know i
mean yeah yeah
fair enough
okay well this isn't about crazy women
but actually sort of is because the girl
in this is kind of crazy okay but so
jordan peterson psychologist he
is famous because he wouldn't use trans
pronouns but not for the reason you
think
so he was a professor in canada and they
said to him you have to use
trans pronouns
in his lectures no like like if you have
a student that's a trans person you have
to use the pronouns and he said i'm not
going to do that but not because i want
to be disrespectful because he doesn't
believe the government has the right to
say what you can and cannot say oh
that's true yeah
so so
that's that that was and so he said i'm
protesting this law i'm not doing it
and then automatically the left just
like hated him oh wow because they're he
they were saying oh you hate trans
people
i think that's the case
but yeah no it's not yeah but so this is
he's on a book tour because he wrote a
book about to help men okay well it
could help anyone but men mostly you'll
see
but this is an interview for the book
you you what i've been telling young men
is that there's an actual reason why
they need to grow up which is that they
have something to offer you know that
that
that people have within them this
capacity to set the world straight and
that's necessary to manifest in the
world and that also doing so is where
you find the meaning that sustains you
in life so what's gone wrong then
oh god all sorts of things have gone
wrong i i think that
i don't think that young men are
hear words of encouragement some some of
them never in their entire lives as far
as i can tell that's what they tell me
and the fact that the words that i've
been that i've been speaking the youtube
lectures that i've done and put online
for example have had such a dramatic
impact is an indication that
young men are starving for this sort of
message because like why in the world
would they have to derive it from a
lecture on youtube now they're not being
taught that they that it's important to
develop yourself but does it does it
bother you that your audience is
predominantly
male does that isn't isn't that a bit
divisive no i don't think so i mean it's
no more divisive than the fact that
youtube is primarily male and tumblers
isn't it tumblr is primarily female
but you're just saying that's the way it
is well it's i'm not saying anything
it's just an observation that that's the
way it is um there's plenty of women
that are watching my lectures and coming
to my talks and buying my books it's
just that the majority of them happen to
be men
uh it's what's in it for the women
though
well what sort of partner do you want
you want an overgrown child
or do you want someone to contend with
that's going to help you do your rely on
women have some sort of duty to sort of
help fix the crisis of masculinity it
depends on what they want
no i mean it's exactly exactly how i
laid it out like
women want
deeply want men who are competent and
powerful
and and i don't mean power in in the in
the in that they can exert tyrannical
control over others that's not power
that's just corruption
power is competence
and why in the world would you not want
a competent partner well i i know why
actually you can't dominate a competent
power partner so if you want me you
should dominate is that what you're
saying no i'd say women who have had
their relationships impaired with
impaired
their relationships with men
impaired and who are afraid of such
relationships will settle for a weak
partner because they can dominate them
but it's a sub-optimal solution do you
think there's not a lot of women
i think there's a substantial minority
of women who do that and i think it's
very bad for them they're very unhappy
it's very bad for their partners
although their partners get the
advantage of not having to take any
responsibility but what gives you the
right to say that i mean maybe that's
how women want their relationships those
women i mean you're making these vast
generalizations
i'm a clinical psychologist right so
you're saying you've done your research
and women are unhappy dominating men
i didn't say they were unhappy
dominating then i said it was a bad
long-term solution
what do you think
you know i agree with exactly what he's
saying like i completely agree with him
it's true um
like he's trying to i agree from um in
the terms of like the book right he's
trying to like help men grow because in
society
like as he's the term that he used
overgrown overgrown children men not
overgrown children and they never work
on themselves and that's because society
has made it a way
where like men are not allowed to be
emotional they don't go to psychiatrists
they don't like seek out help and i kind
of like what he's well i'm kind of like
what he's doing because he's trying to
like
stop that norm from happening to men and
making them a competent partner
and i think it's good i don't see
i don't think he's telling them to like
be more emotional though no not
emotional but like i feel like i think
it's like take more responsibility of
your life yeah yeah yeah because i feel
like back in the days even like women
and men are like
no one used to ever think about mental
health or like
fixing themselves before they get into
relationships or having children so like
their relationships would be crazy like
mad toxic and
like they'll
how do you say it like their children
would
they i don't know how to explain it but
they won't be ready fit mentally ready
for children and stuff like that and
that's because sometimes their
relationships are not right or sometimes
they've never gotten help like
or thick tried to fix themselves you
know what's interesting
i've noticed that
like we i feel like we have more therapy
than ever and self-help industry and
today
but i think we have more mental issues
than ever yeah so like i i ask this
question a lot and i don't i'm not
pretending i have the answer but like
why if we have more self-help and
therapy and stuff do we have more mental
health issues maybe it's because we're
starting to become aware that like
some of the things that we're doing is
actual actually issues like we're
starting to understand that like we're
not doing this because that's how we are
but it's probably like a trauma response
from back when you as a child and it's
just
like society is making these things more
like open
and obviously google and like social
media in general like we're
understanding and we're learning more
than like in the past generation so it's
easier to understand where you have an
issue but to me i don't know because i i
just i'd be thinking a lot
and so i'll be thinking like
like if if i'm just fixating on what
happened in my childhood like i feel
like that would hurt me more than help
because like like my dad was going a lot
growing up and if i just fixated on that
all the time and was like oh is this
like why i choose this type of like
i don't know i don't think that would
help me no it won't help you but i feel
like um you might have
so
you might
do something subconsciously sorry you
might do something subconsciously like
all the time and you don't realize it as
a result of
that happening in your childhood and do
you want to like
bring that on to your children or don't
you want to like fix that problem so you
don't have you don't bring that kind of
right
vibe into you i'm not i'm not like
anti-therapy either i just wonder like
why why would we have more therapy is
there like more issues yeah i do i do
find that weird but maybe you were just
as i said before maybe we're just more
open like we understand that some of the
things we're doing is actually problems
it's not it's not um normal it is normal
of course but it's a trauma response
sometimes it's not like
yeah
yeah
okay you said it was making them
miserable yes it is and it depends on
the time frame i mean there can be
there's intense pleasure in momentary
domination that's why people do it all
the time but it's no smasher pass jordan
peterson
pause he's like he's like
twice my age
i just do this with that reaction
i pass too sorry jordan i love you
though how much money does he have an
object
you be good
formula for a long-term successful
long-term relationship that's reciprocal
right any long-term relationship is
reciprocal
virtually by definition
so
let me put a quote to you from the book
where you say there are whole
disciplines in universities forthrightly
hostile towards men these are the areas
of study dominated by the post-modern
stroke neo-marxist claim that western
culture in particular is an oppressive
structure created by white men to
dominate and exclude women but then i
want to put minorities too dominating
okay sure but i want to put to you that
here in the uk for example let's take
that as an example the gender pay gap
stands at just over nine percent
you've got women at the bbc recently
saying that the broadcaster is illegally
paying them less than men to do the same
job you've got only seven women running
the top ftse 100 companies
so it seems to a lot of women that
they're still being dominated and
excluded to quote your words back to you
it does seem that way but multivariate
analysis of the pay gap indicate that it
doesn't exist
but that's just not true is it i mean
that's nine percent kept pay gap that's
a gap between median hourly earnings
between men and women but that exists
yeah but there's multiple reasons for
that one of them is gender but it's not
the only reason like if you're a social
scientist worth worth your salt you
never do a univariate analysis
like you say well women
in aggregate are paid less than men okay
well then we break it down by age we
break it down by occupation we break it
down by interest we break it down by
personality but you're saying basically
it doesn't matter if women aren't
getting to the top because that's what's
skewing that gender pay gap isn't it
you're saying well that's just a fact
up with it i'm saying that the claim
that the wage gap between men and women
is only due to sex is wrong and it is
wrong there's no doubt about that the
multivariate analysis have been done
well i can give you
i'm saying that nine percent pay gap
exists that's a gap between men and
women i'm not saying why it exists but
it exists now if you're a woman that
seems pretty unfair
you have to say why it exists but do you
agree that it's unfair if you're a woman
not necessarily and on average you're
getting paid 9 less than a man that's
not fair is it
it depends on why it's happening
i can give you an example
okay
there's a personality trait known as
agreeableness
agreeable people are compassionate and
polite
and agreeable people get paid less than
just less agreeable people for the same
job
women are more agreeable than men
again a vast generalization sometimes
that's true but that's right and some
women get paid more than men so you were
saying that by and large women are too
agreeable to get the pay rises so i'm
saying that that's one component of a
multivariate equation that predicts
um salary
what do you think
i don't know i feel like he he's making
some really good points
but
he did say like it's not
like it's true like we don't know we
don't specifically know the reason why
there's a pay gap it could be because i
feel like sometimes like
like i feel like when someone hires a
woman into the company especially like a
woman of
like middle age not middle agery like 25
plus probably um
the potential of them starting a family
and going on maternity leave and stuff
like that that's that's there's a higher
percentage obviously than a man so
companies usually
i don't know if this is an actual thing
but this is probably just like from my
perspective i believe that companies
will probably pay
me less
than a man
if i if we go into the same role because
the likelihood of me actually doing the
job at the same amount of time that a
man's doing a job will be less because
i'll probably have at least two kids so
i'll be that will be out for two years
for each kid it's like four years of not
working and just getting paid like
sitting at home and looking after the
kids
yeah but i don't know i look at
engineering
that's like a very male dominated field
they recruit women they're like begging
women to come in
and i hear guys complain all the time
with the sale she just got that job
because she's a girl and they want they
need them yeah i mean i understand that
but um stuff like engineering
i feel like a woman will
will not take that job because
engineering that's ass yeah like firstly
it's it's a it's long hours especially
like a person as i said before of the
age of 25 plus when they're ready to
start a family it's not it's not
beneficial for like family wise you're
working 80 hours plus a week when you
get pregnant you probably have to stop
working like
probably after four months because it's
gonna it's too much it's too strenuous
and stuff like that so i feel like a
woman
that wants to start a family which is uh
not every woman but like vast majority
of women in society um they wouldn't
take jobs like that it's interesting 50
of women over 30 are single and
childless
and you know so another interesting stat
60 of women have never asked for a raise
yeah you know i'd be kind of scheduled
i'm sorry i don't know why
no and it's interesting because like i'm
on the other side right because i'm
starting to like
like hire people and i could see why
being disagreeable would make you more
money yeah because like the men will say
if
i if i go to you and i say hey
will you take
let's say like 10 bucks an hour right
and then like someone that's
disagreeable is going to say no give me
12. i'm not doing it unless i get 12.
and then they get more money okay or
vice versa they'll say like
like a like
or if you just agree to it that's like
the lowest rate you know what i'm saying
yeah it's true because i feel like even
me if i went into
a place like when i do drop in because
i've had loads of jobs since i was like
16 so when i go to job interviews
i just want to get a job so i'll just be
like whatever like
whatever you want not whatever you want
to pay me but yeah at least above
minimum wage
no but i'm serious and it's not i don't
think it's like the employers being
malicious but they're trying to make as
much money as they can yeah it's true so
it's like what if i say
i want 12 pounds an hour and you're
giving me like um you're offering 10
pounds an hour and then you're like nah
you know what we could only give you 10
pounds an hour like
yeah
well then you go and find another job
that's true but it's so hard to find
jobs is it
maybe because i'm because i'm an
undergrad but it's like it's it's kind
of hard to find jobs what are what's
your major sports and exercise science
okay i mean i don't i'm not i don't job
hunt in the uk yeah yeah well i don't
know like
obviously we're in london it's like a
really competitive and stuff like that
so you have to make sure that your cv is
like outstanding you know how to talk
in interviews like
it's kind of hard like
you could do a year worth of job hunting
and i've done that before but this was
like for little jobs like
part-time jobs but i did like a couple
months worth of job hunting and i've
been i went to like at least 10 15
interviews
yeah after that's the 16th interview
whatever after 16 interviews i i would
just take it yeah take whatever i want
like you'll be like
yeah 700 sure
sure
i've never done that many interviews in
my life yeah i don't know if i did that
much but i did a lot like
i had a
co-op interview like three times and i
never like didn't give you the job at
the co-op yeah well they didn't give me
the job you know i'm saying that
their employers don't even do anything
i've seen them get robbed and the
employees just like stand there i
wouldn't get involved
if i get involved but it's true it's
like they and their application process
is actually very long and they're like
they're like oh we're so into community
oh my god i'm really getting on to
no i'm just like
i i think you'd be better than most the
people that i said i know
they don't even catch you up they have
like five um self checkouts no one's
ever at the tail
like i don't want to buy alcohol like i
have to i have to physically go around
the shop looking you missed out honestly
you missed her
anyways
kind of jumpstarting
[Laughter]
it accounts for maybe five percent of
the variance something like that so
surely we need about another 20 we
needed about another 18 factors one of
which is gender and there is prejudice
there's no doubt about that but it
accounts for a much smaller proportion
of the variance in the pay gap than the
radical feminists claim okay so rather
than denying the pay gap exists which is
what you did at the beginning of this
conversation shouldn't you say to women
rather than being agreeable and not
asking per for a pay rise go and ask for
a pay right make yourself disagreeable
with your book oh definitely there's
that but i also didn't deny it existed i
denied it it existed because of gender
okay because i'm very very very
careful with my words
so the pay gap exists you accept that
but you're saying
i mean the pay gap between men and women
exists but you're saying it's not
because of gender it's because women are
too agreeable to ask for pay rises one
of the reasons okay one of the reasons
so why not get them to ask for a pay
right i've done that
many many times in my career and they
just counseled oh they do it all the
time you can it's so one of the things
that you do as a clinical psychologist
is um assertiveness training so you
might say
often you treat people for anxiety you
treat them for depression
um
and you and maybe the next most common
category after that would be
assertiveness training and so i've had
many many women extraordinarily
competent women in my clinical and
consulting practice and we put together
strategies for their career development
that involve continual pushing competing
for higher wages and often tripled their
wages within a five-year period
of course so
do you actually do you agree that you
would be happy
if that pay gap was eliminated
completely because that's all the
radical feminists are saying it would
depend on how it was eradicated and how
the how how the disappearance of it was
measured and you're saying if it's at
the cost of men that's a problem oh
there's all sorts of things that it
could be at the cost of it could even be
at the cost of women's own interests
so because they might not be happy if
they get equal pay
no because it might interfere with other
things that are causing the pay gap that
women are choosing today like having
children well or choosing careers that
actually happen to be paid less which
women do a lot of but why shouldn't
women have the right to choose not to
have children or the right to choose
those demanding they do they can
yeah that's fine but you're saying that
makes them unhappy by and large i'm
saying that that no i'm not saying that
i'm i and i actually haven't said that
so far you're saying it makes them
miserable no i said that what was making
them miserable was having part was
having weak partners
that makes them miserable right um i
would say that many women around the age
of i would say between 28 and 32 have a
career family crisis that they have to
deal with and i think that's partly
because of the foreshortened time frame
that women have to contend with like
women have to
get the major pieces of their life put
together faster than men which is also
partly why men aren't under so much
pressure to grow up so because for the
typical woman
she has to have her career and family in
order
pretty much by the time she's 35 because
otherwise the options start to run out
and so that puts a tremendous amount of
stress on women especially at the end of
their 20s
i agree with him 100
because um what age was it
that women can't have kids anymore
oh it's it's varied from women to women
right
yeah it's basically 90 of your eggs are
gone by the time you're 30. is it
geriatric pregnancy starts at 35
and around 45 is menopause so it's it
depends when you get menopause so like
yeah my mom's in her 50s she hasn't
gotten it yet like my my family like
it's
older for whatever reason yeah same with
my family because my mom she had my
little brother like
how does he know he's six years ago and
she's around she had him when she was
40.
yeah that's that's rare yeah it's rare
yeah but she said it was so hard that
she would never she obviously she does
her last child but she would not have
any other kids really what'd she say
about it she said it was like she's
she's obviously she's had five kids
right so
she's five kids wow yeah yeah okay yeah
i've got older sister my older sister's
like how does she she's eight years
older than me so um she's had five kids
and she said like she had one when she
was 36 and one when she was 40. and
those two was the hardest
births she had to give but the ones with
because i was born when she was in her
20s and so was my sisters so
she said obviously it was miles easier
and um when she had the last two she had
to get a c-section not uh really yeah
because it was what made it harder like
i don't actually i never actually had
she's sick
she was out for a while though like when
she gave like birth with us she she
she said it was like
she was able to move around after like
freely but we used to have to help her
up and down the stairs like
oh so it was wow yeah it was more
strenuous but then again that could be
because of the c-section because she had
us with normal birth but right well
probably she probably had it something
to do with her age yeah yeah yeah that's
that might be the reason as well but
i feel like
it's true i feel like we do as women we
do have pressure to like be read like
family ready at a certain age or um have
to grow up because i've always noticed
this um
us women we grow up way faster than men
way faster than men like and i don't
sometimes it's not even your parents
drilling and drilling it down your
throat
but you we have to literally
mature faster
and stuff i don't even know why like
i think it's our biology maybe because
you know before people were popping out
babies at like 16
and nowadays um
and so if you don't get your [ __ ]
together by 35 like you you may never be
a mom yeah it's true where men like you
they could be a dad up to they're people
that have fathered kids in their 70s
yeah
that's why
i could understand why girls that that
are younger go for guys that are older
yeah older yeah yeah sometimes it's for
the money but some of the times it's
because the guy is like kind of ready
and to mature well and that they can
stay home like i mean i don't think it's
a bad thing i think it's a bad thing to
go for a guy just for money but i don't
think it's a bad thing to look at a guy
as a source of security so you could
stay home with the kids you know i don't
really like staying i don't i don't
think i could stay home
i actually don't think i i think i'd
probably be more happy as a working wife
yeah but
i i really think it's cool when women
like dedicate their lives to their
children because i want to dedicate my
whole life to them but
i just feel like
i don't know i'm so i'm so
independent i don't know how to explain
it i'm never because
at a young age i didn't even rely on my
family like i just i started working at
a young age so i always used to get my
own money i never used to ask something
like that and i can't even see myself
like
having like having to depend on someone
else it's so weird well you do if you
want to retire yeah yeah that's the
thing yeah you need 2.5 million
that's why i'm gonna work my ass off
whilst i'm young and then have 2.5
million in retirement or hear me out
hear me out marry rich
actually
[Laughter]
[Music]
but
it's it's like i don't fault girls that
take that route because it's like you
want to work for
you know working's cool now but 30 40
years ago yeah it's true it's a long
time i feel like um
if you do get like a guy that's secure
like has enough money to like support
you i feel like you have you open
windows to do stuff that you like work
in things that you want to work in not
stuff that you have to work in so it's
not working yeah
yeah so
i do
like i understand the security part of
it yeah
i think i take issue with the idea of
the typical woman because you know all
women are different and that's what i
want to just put another quote to you
from the book different in some ways and
the same in others
okay you say women become more
vulnerable when they have children and
you talk to one of your youtube
interviews about crazy happy sisters
so
simple question is gender equality a
myth in your view is that something
that's just never going to happen
it depends on what you mean by equality
getting the same opportunities
fairly people could we could get to a
point where people were treated fairly
or more fairly i mean people are treated
pretty fairly in western culture already
but we can they're really not though are
they i mean otherwise why would there
only be seven women running ftse 100
companies in the uk why why would there
still be a pay gap which we've discussed
at length why are women at the bbc
saying that they're getting paid
illegally less than men to do the same
job well that's not fair let's go to the
first question they're both complicated
questions seven seven women repeat that
one there's seven women running the top
ftse 100 companies in the uk well the
first the first question might be um why
would you want to do that
why would a man want to do it
of men although not that many
who are perfectly willing to sacrifice
virtually all of their life
to the pursuit of a high-end career so
they'll work these are men that are very
intelligent they're usually very very
conscientious they're very driven
they're very high energy they're very
healthy and they're willing to work 70
or 80 hours a week non-stop specialized
at one thing to get to the top so you're
saying women are just more sensible they
don't want that because it's not an
isolated i'm saying that's part of it
definitely and so i work
you don't think there are barriers in
their way that prevent them getting to
the top there are some barriers yeah
like other like men for example i mean
to get to the top of any organization is
an incredibly competitive enterprise and
the men that you're competing with are
simply not going to roll over and say
please take the position
absolutely all out warfare is gender
equality a myth
i don't know what you mean by the
question men and women aren't the same
and they won't be the same that doesn't
mean they can't be treated fairly is
gender equality desirable
if it means equality of outcome then
almost certainly it's undesirable that's
already been demonstrated in scandinavia
because in scandinavia i mean by that
equality of outcome is undesirable well
men and women won't sort themselves into
the same categories if you leave them
alone to do it off their own accord i've
already seen that in scandinavia it's 20
to one
female nurses
to male something like that it might not
be quite that extreme and approximately
the same male engineers to female
engineers and that's a consequence of
the free choice of men and women in the
societies that have gone farther than
any other societies to make gender
equality the purpose of the law those
are inerratical differences you can
eradicate them with tremendous social
pressure and tyranny but if you leave
men and women to make their own choices
you will not get equal outcomes right
that's true
i agree with that as well i keep
agreeing with this guy he keeps making
really good points isn't he smart yeah
he's so smart yeah
you've heard you've heard me on the show
talk about this yeah
i was like oh whoa isn't um that like
literally what you say all the time i
give credit where credit is due i'm not
the smart one he's the smart one
yeah i do feel like when it comes to
choosing jobs like even me
okay i would like to work as well
um play basketball and earn money but
obviously bro i can't there's no way
like yeah guys make like butlers
compared to girls
and i probably have to sacrifice that
dream to do something
better i mean something i could make
more money in but the stuff that to make
more money in is like long tedious and
hard so i might find something that i
like and is pretty easy to do
or something that is decent
and i'm not stressed out all about all
the time about it you know what i mean
yeah well i always say i don't think
most people because my dad's very
successful but i don't think most people
would do what he did yeah that's the
thing
everything comes everything comes at a
cost and the cost to him was he really
wasn't around a lot i'm really close
with him now he got to retire early i
no hate you know but it's just like
that that was part of the cost
and i think
like most women at some age are just
like screw this what am i doing all this
for i have enough money also be because
of like
like we said before um women having like
kind of a time scale
i feel like because we feel like because
as he said before he's like women want
to be
or did you say that women have to be
secure by like 35.
yeah if they want kids they have to they
have to find a husband yeah basically my
final husband and i feel like we can't
dedicate that much time and effort into
like a career
um
like if we want to have that kind of
like life basically a kid driven life so
that's that's probably the reason why in
like western societies women choose
easier jobs and jobs that are not as
demanding as men
yeah
is it i love him i love showing people
this video
you're saying that anyone who believes
in equality whether you call them
feminists call them whatever you want to
call them should basically give up
because it ain't going to happen
why does she do this i don't know why
she said that like
like you you clearly that's not what
he's saying he didn't say that he's just
saying that in western societies women
choose easier jobs right and it's not
that it's not equal it's just that we
want we want easier jobs yeah
well women tend to excel in fields with
people
yes true and men tend to excel in fields
with things it's just things make more
money
than people
like a counselor is not going to make
he's going to make as much money as an
engineer yeah that's true but you see
he'll talk more about this
only if they're aiming at equality of
outcome
you're saying give people equality of
opportunity that's fine not only fine
it's eminently desirable for everyone
for individuals and for society but
still women aren't going to make it
that's what you're really saying depends
on your measurement techniques they're
doing just fine in medicine
in fact there are far more female
physicians than there are male
physicians there there are lots of lots
of disciplines that are absolutely
dominated by women many many disciplines
and they're doing great
so let me put something else to you from
the book you say the introduction of the
equal pay for equal work argument
immediately complicates even salary
comparison beyond practicality for one
simple reason who decides what work is
equal it's not possible so the simple
question is do you believe in equal pay
well i made the argument there it's like
it depends
no i'm not saying that at all because a
lot of people listening to you will just
say i mean are we going back to the
doctor that's okay you're actually not
listening i'm just looking very
carefully and i'm hearing you basically
saying women need to just accept they're
never gonna make it on equal terms equal
outcomes is what how you defined it
she's
funny that's not like
oh my god she's not understanding what
he's saying
she's just because she's listening to
response she's just like looking at her
notes
she married
is that a ring probably wait
yeah that's what that sound
she can't still be married i don't
believe it
who is this woman who married this woman
i think most women are like this though
you think so wrong and strong
really like when i'm wrong i have to be
right
when you're in an argument and you're
wrong though you want like
yeah but you've gotten into arguments on
my show and you don't you don't act like
this
yeah but i don't think i am i'm an
embodiment of normal
everyday women
that's true there's a lot of yeah i i
think more reasonable girls come on my
show because they're like they can have
these conversations because early on
a different set of girls came on but
they didn't last too long
they tend to they tend to wee these
you know who didn't come back
you can't please everyone no i didn't if
i was a young woman watching that i
would go well i might as well just go
and play with my cindy dolls i'd give up
trying at school because i'm not going
to get the top job i want because
there's someone sitting there saying
it's not possible
i didn't say that women shouldn't be
striving for the top or anything like
that because i don't believe that for a
second striving for the top but you're
going to put all those hurdles in their
way as has been in their way for
centuries and that's fine you're saying
that's fine no no i think i really the
patriarchal system is just that's silly
i do i think that's silly i really do i
mean look look at your situation you're
hardly unsuccessful yeah and i have how
do you work hard together exactly
good that's okay battling is good this
is also inevitable but you talk about
men first let me just put another thing
to you from the bottom you're saying you
have to battle for a high quality
position
well i notice in your book you talk
about real conversations between men
containing quote and underlying threat
of physicality oh there's no doubt about
that what about real conversations
between women is that something are we
sort of too amenable and reasonable
no it's just that
the domain of physical conflict is sort
of off limits for you
well you just said that i thought to get
where i've got yeah but what does that
make me i don't know
i don't imagine that you've yeah to some
degree i suspect you're not very
agreeable so that's the thing success
for women i'm not very agreeable right
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah but i feel like she's she's kind of
like um
disregarding everything that he's saying
and then saying putting jumping it all
up into some like
and exploding it and it's not what he's
saying like she's she said something
about cindy dolls you tell it basically
if i was a young girl um watching this
show
i should just go and play with my dolls
because i can't get into a better
position like i don't understand why
she's going in like
i don't understand why she's doing that
well and it's hitting the hand that
feeds you i don't did he talk about how
he helps women negotiate raises no oh
that's later i i forget but
but he he helps women with this stuff
and he's a psychologist so that's what
he does he's he helps men and women but
he's just given a realist kind of
view yeah yeah it's not offensive to say
like i don't think youtube tends to be
the highest paying job but i love doing
this yeah and if i make less money doing
it whatever yeah i feel like that's the
thing as well sometimes guys might do
jobs that they don't like but
they are getting a lot of money from it
and we were like nah
nah i'm not doing that oh my gosh
there's a youtuber who said okay if
there was a
a job in alaska
that paid you two hundred thousand
dollars a year
most girls wouldn't move to take it and
most men would like run and jump at the
chance
wait i have to move there
that seems interesting i would actually
do it i would too yeah but i think we're
the exception rather than yeah yeah i
don't think most
girls would 202 that's a lot of money
that's yeah but like it's because you
can do it for two three years yeah and
then
what the hell
definitely do that i i would but you see
i don't think most girls would yeah but
then again i feel like sometimes um i
don't know if it's because we play
sports
or or something but a lot of
people like
me and you
we
tend to think differently than most
girls
yeah i i don't want to say we're
different
i don't think i think i'm different it's
like we're the same it's just there's
like a type of girl i talk to and i
could just tell they're like harder
workers and they're like trying to get
like yeah they're trying to build [ __ ]
too
yeah but it's more common i think in
sports that's what i've noticed but i
feel like it's because we're we're in a
like we're in the industry where we
actually have to work our asses off to
continue to play because really and
truly what money are we getting
exactly
and um it's a male dominated area so i'm
not surprised that a lot of girls that
are hard working
um and have the same kind of mindset
that we do are usually in sports yeah
because i know that girls like they
usually give up like after high school
no they do
and most girls are
and it makes you not as involved in
superficial [ __ ] yeah like because you
can't be obsessed you don't have time to
be obsessed with like shopping and like
all this yeah
it's funny because um
i my friend i used to send my friend
money to shop for me
because i never used to me too i hate
shopping yeah but then now that i'm
going on a holiday in jamaica and like
oh next month yeah i got this shopping
bug but i feel like it's probably just a
phase because i'm going on holiday yeah
but i've never had it before like i've
never spent more than 50 pounds on the
clothes i'm not gonna lie oh my gosh do
you know yeah i'm the same way yeah like
i only spend my money i spend a boatload
on equipment yeah
but it's funny though because women
hold
like
i don't want to say the stat wrong but
they hold three quarters of the consumer
debt despite making less money than men
it's crazy
but then it's like um women are valued
because we look nice though yeah and
then they they consume the consuming
market is targeted towards like beauty
and stuff like that yeah but then you'd
think we wouldn't because a lot of our
debt is from education in the u.s anyway
so you'd think
but i've also noticed also girls that
are dead broken they still get filler
i'm like how do you have filler money i
don't understand
i just don't want it that bad
i guess they have people to pay for it
i don't know i don't ask questions but
it served your career well successful
women though basically have to wear the
trousers in your view they have to sort
of become men to succeed is what you're
saying well if they're going i've had to
fight to succeed
man certainly masculine traits are going
to be helpful i mean one of the things i
do in in my counseling
practice for example when i'm consulting
with women who are trying to advance
their careers is to teach them how to
negotiate and to and to be able to say
no and to not be easily pushed around
and to be formidable and you need to if
you're going to be successful you need
to be smart
conscientious and tough well here's a
radical idea why don't the bosses adopt
some the male bosses shall we say adopt
some female traits so that women don't
have to fight and get their sharp elbows
out for the pay rises it's just accepted
if they're doing the same job they get
the same pay
well i would say partly because it's not
so easy to determine what constitutes
the same job and almost because
arguably yeah there are still men
dominating our industries our society
and therefore they've dictated the terms
for so long that women have to battle to
know that it's not true
it's not true so for example well i can
give you an example very quickly so i
worked with women who worked in
high-powered law firms in canada for
about 15 years and they were as
competent and put together as anybody
you would ever meet and we were trying
to figure out how to further their
careers
and there was a huge debate in canadian
society at that point that was basically
ran along the same lines as your
argument is that if the
law firms didn't use these masculine
criteria then perhaps women would do
better but the market sets the damn game
it's like and the market is dominated by
men no it's not it's not the market is
dominated by women they make 80 of the
consumer decisions that's not the case
at all if you're talking about people
who stay at home looking after children
by and large they are still women so
they're going out doing the shopping but
that is changing they make all these
what are what
okay ma'am do you not have amazon
do you know what i find funny when it
comes to um shopping right is uh the
kids section and the men's section is
right next to each other and the women's
section is on its own floor like usually
if there's a two floors
the woman has its own floor it's huge
like there's clothes everywhere and then
the upstairs is half kids and half men's
you know what else is funny they'll
market thanks to men but for like
products for men but towards women right
yeah so she could buy it for her husband
yeah i've seen that that's why the men
in the kids section are discovered
because she's gonna pass the men's
section to get to the kids section and
then she'll like oh that might look nice
on my husband oh that might look nice on
my kid then she'll buy that as well i
just i don't think girls are as good
with money in general yeah it's true
it's true some girls like they're i know
i could name a lot of girls that like
aren't like that
but i'm not good with money i don't know
where it comes from
i'm just not good
but but for every like one i meet five
that i actually you don't seem like
you'd be that bad because like
you don't seem like most girls i know
spend stupid amounts of money on like
clothes i spend on food that's the
problem yeah that's me too
i like eating i like eating
yeah but i i like cooking so i like
eating like yeah nice food like i bought
20 pound worth of prawns the other day
and it was also in my freezer well not
all i mean i'm going to make some today
but i get hungry sometimes yeah like
sure
i'd be free
okay
so the market is driven by women not men
right okay and if you're a lawyer they
still pay more for the same sort of
goods
that's been proven that men for the you
buy a blue bicycle helmet it's going to
cost less than a pink one anyway we'll
come on to that partly because men are
less agreeable
right so so they won't put up with it i
want to ask you
is it not desirable to have some of
those female traits you're talking about
i'd say that's a generalization but
you've used the words female traits is
it not desirable to have some of them at
the top of business i mean maybe they
wouldn't have they don't produce a
banking crisis they don't predict
success in the workplace the things that
predict success in the workplace are
intelligence and conscientiousness
agreeableness negatively predicts
success in the workplace
you're saying that women aren't
intelligent enough to run these top
companies no i didn't say that at all
you said that
female traits don't predict success but
i didn't say that intelligence wasn't i
didn't say that intelligence and
conscientiousness well you were saying
not saying that at all are women less
intelligent than men no no no they're
not no the the data on that's pretty
clear the average iq for a woman in the
average iq for a man is identical there
is some debate about the flatness of the
distribution which is something that
james demore pointed out for example in
his memo but there's no difference at
all in general cognitive ability there's
no difference to speak of in
conscientiousness women are a bit more
orderly than men
and men are a little bit more
industrious than women but the
difference isn't big i don't think that
averages into contemporary any men who
aren't necessarily well of course
why are they not feminine treats why are
they not desirable at the top of
feminine traits why are they not
desirable at the top it's hard to say
i'm just laying out the empirical
evidence like we know that we know the
traits that predict success but we also
know because companies by and large have
not been dominated by women over the
centuries we have nothing to compare it
to
it's an experiment true and it could be
the case that if companies modified
their behavior and became more feminine
they would be successful but there's no
evidence for it i'm not neither doubtful
nor non-doubtful there's no evidence why
not give it a go as the radical because
the evidence suggests well it's fine if
like if someone wants to start a company
and make it more feminine and
compassionate let's say and caring in
its overall orientation towards its
workers and towards the marketplace then
that's a perfectly reasonable experiment
to run my point is that there is no
evidence that those traits predict
success in the workplace and there's
positives
well that's not that's not really the
case women have been in the workplace
for what at least
ever since i've been around the
representation of women in the workplace
has been about 50 so we've run the
experiment for a fairly reasonable
period of time but not you know
certainly not for centuries let me move
on to another debate that's
what been you think
um
she just i can't i don't really like her
[Laughter]
she she
she's saying that feminine traits
like i underst i don't really understand
what feminine traits are though like
okay
i know there's the debate with the
agreeable and disagreeable thing and i i
understand that we are we are more
agreeable but what other
feminine traits do we have that well
that's the biggest one and i'll give you
an example in basketball
i have been passed over a lot of times
to be captain to be a captain
and it's because we probably have we're
probably more agreeable than we are
disagreeable have you ever noticed the
girls that tend to be captains are a
little bit [ __ ]
like they're a little bit more take
charge
tell everyone what to do
yeah actually
yeah actually every team i've been on
i've kind of been the captain or like
that's true though yeah that's true or
they have that kind of aura around them
where they're like
because when we was in first year we
used to have a girl she was she was
obviously older than all of us so we
just looked up to her yeah and she was
the captain but i feel like
i understand that it's true like and
i've i've been a captain before but it's
usually because it's not because i'm i'm
the biggest lead like you play with me
i'm not the type that's gonna take
charge of a drill tell everyone what to
do even if i have the experience it's
just not my personality
i'm more like the enthusiastic
cheerleader yeah i'm like get it but
but that's as a boss
it's better to be disagreeable yes and
even now when i run decisions i run them
a lot of times through guys because
they they're just or
not i understand what you mean yeah it's
like um if your manager or like someone
of high high um
like in a job um you need to be able to
have us like be stunned you can't just
let everything slide you know yes and
then there we do have trades that like
allows a lot of things to slide or will
laugh and stuff like that and people
could think that they could like take
the piss or come to work late all the
time and stuff yeah and it's not
necessarily like a bad thing like like
um
it makes you a better mother it makes
you more compassionate but just in that
field it's just not great a lot of the
time but i feel like it's easy to adopt
many traits because i feel like for me
i've been a captain a couple times and
sometimes i have to realize that i
actually have to take charge like
sometimes people like if people are
coming late training all the time i'll
be like okay if you come to late
training today you're going to run and
stuff like that like sometimes you like
at first obviously i wouldn't do that
i'd be like i don't really care but then
if training isn't starting until
everyone's here then i have to put my
foot down oh for sure it definitely can
be learned but yeah but if one per if
one group naturally does it and one
group naturally doesn't yeah the group
that naturally does it is going to have
an advantage yeah but i feel like that
kind of stuff can be like
taught in like schools and stuff
yeah but leader because in school well i
don't know about america but here we um
because i did obviously sports in school
we used to do this leadership thing like
we used to literally
just have a course called leadership and
it was obviously it was anyone that was
involved in sports and you need to be
able to lead a session
yeah but even with that right you've
been you've been a captain
you did the course
you still have never asked for a raise
that's true
and it's not it's no don't knock to you
i've i i work for myself now so
i can't say i've ever done it either i
feel like i don't know
maybe if i'm like it's true i feel like
sometimes i'm just complacent like if
i'm making money i'm all right yeah
so i'm just like oh i don't you don't
care yeah i don't really care but that's
just my personality yeah
been very controversial for you um
and this is you got in trouble for
refusing to call trans men and women by
their preferred personal pronouns
no that's not actually true i got in
trouble because i said i would not
follow the compelled speech dictates of
the federal and provincial government i
actually never got in trouble for not
calling anyone anything right that
didn't happen i wouldn't follow the
change of law which was designed once it
was lost
you cited freedom of speech in that why
should your right to freedom of speech
trump a trans person's
right not to be offended
because in order to be able to think you
have to risk being offensive i mean look
at the conversation we're having right
now
you know like you're certainly willing
to risk offending me in the pursuit of
truth why should you have the right to
do that it's been rather uncomfortable
well i'm i'm very glad i put you on the
spot
well i'm going to buy this but
you get my point it's like you're you're
doing what you should do which is
digging a bit to see what the hell is
going on and that is what you should do
but you're exercising your freedom of
speech to certainly risk offending me
and that's fine i think more power to
you as far as i'm concerned
except you haven't sat there and
i'm just sorry i've just tried to work
that out i mean
ha gotcha you have got me you have got
me i'm trying to work that through my
head yeah yeah it took a while took a
while it did yeah it took a while
you have volunteered
he's so funny
he's like got you [ __ ]
he's running circles around here
honestly
oh gosh out in the interview dave how
was that
i'll be like show's over guys cut the
cameras you know what's crazy she
thought she won they didn't have to air
this
she literally like the reason they aired
it was because she thought she won the
debate that's how delusional but she
he's so like collect because he knows
what he's talking about he's so
collected
and calm and he's just like no like i'm
talking right you're the one that's like
not right and i feel like this
discussion she she shouldn't have been
the one to lead it because she keeps she
she's not listening like
she's just like oh you don't like women
and then it's that's not what he's
saying he's just saying that the reason
why women don't like go back to other
points
reason why women don't like
don't have they have a pay gap is
because women choose this and then she's
like no no
it's unfair like she's not listening to
anything so
i think someone
better should have had discussion with
him
yeah honestly i really want to react to
this video with her oh god
i'd be like kathy what were you doing
that was rude
you should have you should try that that
should be your aim yeah i'm trying kathy
if you see this you're invited
come on
you have voluntarily come into the
studio and agreed to be questioned
a trans person in your class has come to
your class and said they want to be
called that's never happened
and i would call them she so you would
so you've kind of changed your channel
no no no i said that right from the
beginning what i said at the beginning
was that i was not going to cede the
linguistic territory to radical leftists
regardless of whether or not it was put
in law that's what i said and then the
people who came after me said well you
must be transphobic and you'd mistreat a
student in your class it's like i never
mistreated a student in my class i'm not
transphobic and that isn't what i said
well except you've also called trans
campaigners authoritarian haven't you i
mean isn't that well only in the broader
context of my claims that radical
leftist ideologues are uh authoritarian
which they are saying someone who is
trying to work out their gender identity
who may well have struggled with that
had quite a tough time struggle
you're comparing them with you know
chairman mao who no just saw the deaths
of millions of people even if
okay do you understand what he's saying
he's trying to say that he
i kind of understand what he's saying
he's trying to say that he
is not um
with the gov like if the government the
government can't tell me what to do yeah
basically and then she's like
no you're saying that you're transphobic
you're just transphobic aren't you and
then he's like no i'm not well and even
so even more so now he she's saying he
compared it
to countries that have had really big
atrocities happen
um so i i don't know what example they
use but one i think of as north korea
because when the government starts to
have the power to tell you what you can
and cannot say
then they get the power to do
more whatever yeah that's like that's
like that covert thing when it's like um
is this control like you don't was going
to con constantly
is this like because of covet or is this
just a control measure
that's what that's like what a lot of
people
had a problem with and i understand his
point because you don't want the
government to control like those little
like you have a right to say what you
want to say and speak what you want to
speak so
question do you think trans people are
delusional
no
i've never really i've never really had
a much of an opinion on uh trans people
apart from one day when we did that
sports one yeah but um
i just feel like they could just do
whatever they want to do yeah do you do
you think if i said i identify as black
that people would think i was delusional
maybe
yeah 100 that's just like there's
obviously there's certain things in
society that doesn't make sense like
that like
of course um
if a female feels like she's a man she
could identify as a man but i guess
that's kind of crazy so can you can you
physically turn yourself into a
different race
i could paint my skin the same way they
change they chop off their parts yeah
it's like like dress the parts
they dress like it
you don't even like that's all they're
doing it's not changing who they are but
they're just changing
like if anything it'd be easier with
race because i mean not me per se like i
probably wouldn't be the one to do it
but like some white girls could just
tantalize
like that'd be easier than getting a
surgery yeah
or what if they created a surgery where
you could like you know how they bleach
skin like the opposite yeah then am i am
i black
no of course but i look black
yeah
well
that's that's that's the issue when it
comes to um
transgender stuff and i just kind of
just like leave it because i i don't
know where to draw the line because it's
like
i just want like if you want to do what
you want to do like you can do it like
if you want to be yeah a girl if you
want to be a guy
you know just as long as it's not
affecting
us i'm i'm with you yeah like i like
they can they can do whatever they want
it doesn't doesn't affect my life
but i i still think you're delusional
i just felt like it it took a bit far
when it was the swimmer because i'm like
yeah that see there's a line where it i
like you are transgender you do identify
as a girl but then you've obviously got
male genes
in you because you was born as a man so
obviously you're stronger as i've said
before you're stronger
than a female and when it comes to stuff
like that physically like obviously they
can't they can't bear a child i don't
know if they're gonna
have technology for them to do that
eventually but they can't bear a child
so yes they're not a hundred percent of
women a woman and
i feel like they shouldn't participate
in women's sports yeah yeah you know i
think they shouldn't be allowed in the
locker rooms and bathrooms either
yeah yeah that's delusion like you're
not a whole guy because i feel like you
see i don't know if they have it in this
uni did i have it in this uni there's
like
a men's toilet a woman's toilet and then
a gender neutral toilet that's fine yeah
gender-neutral one yeah but don't make
it
a thing where um women
have to try to get comfortable
with someone that was a man like
yesterday
and they turned into a woman today
i'm not getting changed in the same
change like that would be like me
saying i should be in charge of the
black students union after yeah my skin
what the hell yeah no
the activists you know they're trans
people too they have a right to say
these things yeah but they don't have a
right
to their whole community compare them to
chairman mao
you know i could pinochet or gusto
punisher i mean that you know this is
grossly insensitive i didn't compare
them to pinochet well i did compare an
authority he was an authoritarian he was
a right winger though i was comparing
them to the left-wing totalitarians and
i do believe they are left-wing
totalitarians on the
millions of people died right i mean
there's no comparison between a mao and
a trans activist is there
why not
because trans activists aren't killing
millions of people
the philosophy that's guiding their
utterances is the same philosophy
the consequences aren't yet
you're saying that trans activists no
could lead to the deaths of millions of
people no i'm saying that the philosophy
that drives their utterances is the same
philosophy that already has driven us to
the deaths of millions okay tell us how
that philosophy
is in any way comparable
sure that's no problem the first thing
is is that the philosophy presumes that
group identity is paramount
that's the fundamental philosophy that
drove the soviet union in maoist china
and it's the fundamental philosophy of
the left-wing activists it's identity
politics it doesn't matter who you are
as an individual it matters who you are
in terms of your group identity you're
just saying so to provoke aren't you i
mean you are a provocative i never said
you're like the old right that you hate
to be compared to
you want to stir things up i'm only a
provocateur in so far as
when i say what i believe to be true
it's provocative i don't provoke
maybe for you don't sit out now and then
i'm not interested in provoking but what
about the thing about you know
fighting and the lobster tell us about
the lobster
well that's quite a segway well the
first chapter you think he's provoking
no i feel like he's he has an opinion
and people are provoked by it yeah yeah
i don't think he's provoking it sounds
like a damn problem
like if i have say something and you
don't like it
yeah you can talk to me about it but i'm
not provoking you i'm just saying what's
on my mind you know and i don't think
that's provoking anyone
if anything she's provocative
yeah yeah it's like the cat calling the
kettle black yeah
that's so crazy
chapter i have in my book
is called stand up straight with your
shoulders back and it's an injunction to
be combative
not least to further your career let's
say
but also to adopt
a stance of ready engagement with the
world and to reflect that in your
posture and the reason that i
write about lobsters is because there's
this idea that hierarchical structures
are a
sociological construct of the western
patriarchy and that is so untrue that
it's almost unbelievable and i use the
lobster as an example because the
lobster we divulged from lobsters in
evolutionary history about 350 million
years ago common ancestor and lobsters
exist in hierarchies and they have a
nervous system attuned to the hierarchy
and that nervous system runs on
serotonin just like our nervous systems
do and the nervous system of the lobster
and the human being is so similar that
antidepressants work on lobsters and
it's part of my attempt to demonstrate
that the idea of hierarchy has
absolutely nothing to do with
sociocultural construction which it
doesn't let me just get straight you're
saying that we should organize our
societies
along the lines of the lobsters
i'm saying that it's inevitable that
there will be continuity in the way that
animals and human beings organize
organize their structures it's it's
absolutely inevitable and there is one
third of a billion years of evolutionary
history behind that right that's that's
so long that a third of a billion years
ago there weren't even trees
it's a long time you have a mechanism in
your brain that runs on serotonin that's
similar to the lobster mechanism that
tracks your status
and the higher your status the better
your emotions are regulated so as your
serotonin levels increase you feel more
positive emotion and less negative
emotion so you're saying like the
lobsters we're hardwired as men and
women to do certain things to sort of
run along tram lines and there's nothing
we can do about it no i'm not saying
there's nothing we can do about it
because it's like a in a chess game
right there's lots of things that you
can do although you can't break the
rules of the chess game and continue to
play chess biological your your
biological nature is somewhat like that
is it sets the rules of the game but
within those rules you have a lot of
leeway but the idea that but
one thing we can't do is say that
hierarchical organization is a
consequence of the capitalist patriarchy
it's like that's patently absurd it's
wrong it's not a matter of opinion it's
seriously wrong
aren't you just whipping people up into
a state of anger and not at all
divisions between men and women you're
stirring people up you know
any critics of you
i don't understand what you're saying
that's so wrong for her to be so upset
about it
every time she says so you're saying i
know she's going to say something he
didn't say
she's inferring wrong like she's not
infering it right does she go did she do
gcse history oh wait that's probably
something different in america but
okay do you ever
[Music]
wish i wish i could be in some of these
situations because sometimes i feel like
a girl won't respect a guy but if a girl
says the same thing
like she'll listen yeah
i do feel like that because i feel like
if a guy was like to me
um
what could guys if a guy was like to me
females are as soon as they say female 4
my ears switch off and i'm just like
shut up but if a girl what if it's true
though
you don't have an opinion on females
we have opinions on men yeah but my
opinion's not facts because i'm not a
man
i like i think it either is or it is it
yeah i don't care who's saying it
because i feel like there's a lot of
people that just say dumb things about
females just because like a lot of men
sorry a lot of men yeah yeah but sort of
women like it's not bad yeah it's on
both sides so i'm just not going to
listen to this
yeah i'm gonna just keep going
online get absolutely lambasted by your
followers generally
sorry your critics get lambasted by you
i mean if they're irresponsible not at
all if an academic is going to come
after me and tell me that i'm not
qualified and that i'm not i don't know
what i'm talking about
quit the abuse quit the anger
well we'd need some
substantial examples of the abuse and
the anger before i could detail that
question there's a lot of outcome for
well let's take a more general
perspective on that so i've had 25 000
letters since june something like that
from people who told me that i've
brought them back from the brink of
destruction and so i'm perfectly willing
to put that up against the rather vague
accusations that my followers are making
the lives of people that i've targeted
miserable jordan peterson thank you okay
that's the one thing i hate when people
come at my show
and they'll be they'll be mad when they
put their instagram in the description
what do you mean like like because she's
saying sometimes his followers come
after people that like disagree with him
or fight with him right and he can't
control what the internet does yeah it's
true but people will put themselves in a
situation where they're on a platform
and then get mad at the results um
yeah that's why i just don't do it just
if you don't if you
if you don't want if you can't take it
just don't go on any kind of platform
well and it depends how you can like you
haven't gotten a bunch of hate from
being on my show okay
no i know you don't care but i'm saying
like
it's it's based on i think it depends on
the because i feel like sometimes people
i've seen people on the show that would
say something but
it's like
so like society doesn't work like that
like they'll say something so dumb
and then
or even in in general not even just on
your show like in general on tick tock
or like instagram and stuff someone will
say something so dumb or like that's not
right you're going to get hate for that
just like you know that's not right
that's not the way to think but if you
can't take it don't be on the internet
yeah you don't have to be on the
internet yeah you don't have to be so
literally that's why my account's
private
no not even just for that there's other
reasons so then why do you why do you
tell them where to find you oh tick tock
yeah follow my tech talk i take tax
instagram she won't accept your
followers i won't i would why do you
need my instagram for
my post content on tech talkback
oh i put you in the description a lot i
don't really mind i just won't accept it
as it's private but it's literally the
exact same on tiptop i'm only on a
school xox i make anime
so what did you think of jordan peterson
you know what he comes with facts
and
he has he has a nice way of thinking
yeah of course he's a psychologist so he
knows yeah yeah but the whole scene you
know what it reminds me of um you know
the
johnny depp case what's going on right
now it just it was just like johnny that
was so kind of calm and collected like
like the guy and then
the girl was like
trying to make up anything
well we're more emotional yeah in
general yeah there's some there's
something that's the girl's name again i
forgot amber her name's amber heard yeah
that's the girl yeah yeah like she kind
of reminded me of amber the girl
wait not in that sense not in a rude
sense i don't know how you could say
that didn't it not be rude but it's i
could kind of see it though
and you kind of see it though but she
does because she was like on the losing
end and she kept trying to like lie
and say he said something but he didn't
he didn't say that so yeah
yeah oh my god
well thank you for doing this with me i
think these conversations are really
important to have i think they're very
fun
um
okay you have any final thoughts
oh those are my final thoughts well i
just said
yeah she's amber
okay guys um don't forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell also um sign up for memberships
because we're gonna have some membership
perks coming soon that i can't name yet
so
um don't forget to subscribe i'll talk
to you guys next time